we are continuing our partnership with
Ted highlight individuals and ideas
shaping our world in our ideas that
matter series this morning we are
talking to Sir Ken Robinson the man
behind the most watched TED talk of all
time Robinson's 2006 talk do schools
kill creativity was one of the first to
be posted on Ted's website began with a
simple idea so I want to talk about
education and I want to talk about
creativity my contention is that
creativity now is as important in
education as literacy and we should
treat it with the same status more than
56 million views since its release it
has been translated into 62 languages
his latest book you your child and
school navigating your way to the best
education offers parents a guide to help
make important school choices for their
kids Sir Ken Robinson good morning well
good morning thank you John before you
were talking about body type and how
important it is I said to Ken why do you
think your your TED talk is the most
viewed egos look at me they don't know
what you're that's a creative answer but
let me ask you this we've been reporting
all morning about this scandal with
American colleges what does it tell you
that scandal well obviously what's been
going on is illegal its fraudulent and
it's awful but it to me it points to a
much bigger issue which is the entire
system is skewed at the moment there's
an obsession in America with people
going to college the whole k-12
education system is pushed very hard in
that direction kids are getting stressed
out parents are getting stressed schools
are being skewed into all the wrong
directions and this is a multi-billion
dollar industry all these people gaming
the system but trying to improve SAT
scores to get kids to college and I
think honestly it's a false dream and we
ought to review it it's one of your
testing I'm sorry one of in one of your
lectures you say that the dominant
culture of education has come to focus
on testing not teaching and learning so
that directly applies
that's exactly right I mean the you know
arts programs are being cut from school
recess is being khartoum in schools
across the country are getting rid of
recess for children there was a news
report about a program in Texas for a
group of schools that's reinstating
recess so children can play and I think
we've gone mad haven't we there's a news
report children found playing let's say
you're a parent trying to extricate your
system from the for yourself from the
school system as it teaches how do you
encourage and teach creativity with your
kids well there are several things they
just very quickly one of them is that
all children have very different talents
that's the point really that I mean
anybody watching this is not two
children or more I'll bet them they're
entirely different and the world needs
different talents we need different
abilities in this studio depends on
people with all kinds of interests
skills and dispositions so there are all
kinds of routes to success and at the
moment were preoccupied of this
particular route and I say it's a false
hope but the consequence is that it's
denigrated all the other option is you
know the vocational options other
programs that people could take so the
first thing is look at your child as an
individual and take proper stock of
their real talents and abilities one of
your chapters is raise them strong yes
explain what you meant by that I mean
children need to be resilient we need to
let them fall over from time to time I
think we're obsessed with over parenting
yeah that's this college admissions
process let them fail getting into
school into a college something that
they really want he wanted to really
party at school
imagine if that's her motivating factor
if she couldn't get into the school that
you want tell me one of the contents of
this as well by the way is that kids
don't go out and play anymore you know
how much time did you spend playing as a
child all the time we get mud we rode
bicycles and it wasn't some little it
was the mean streets available after the
Second World War we played all the time
we came off in the school we ran out and
played honestly we only really went home
for the food you know we were like we're
like cats I've no idea my natural
parents are college isn't for everybody
there's so much emphasis on you gotta go
you gotta go
I think some people are clutching their
pearls to hear you say it's not for
everybody but you point out it's not for
everybody and that's okay well it's not
because it's not
it's not forever because some people
can't make it yeah my point is that
there are all kinds of talents and
abilities other than those that are
needed to an academic degree and we tend
to denigrate them you know there are all
kinds of vacation options and people
should be taking and the other thing
just to say is that that it won't take
many more students I think leaving
college with degrees that aren't worth
as much as they thought with a mountain
of student debt for the whole scheme
yeah be trees now are going to be
useless
well the role there are many good
reasons to study degree is not just for
work but we're facing an economic
tsunami at the moment of the the spread
of artificial intelligence for example I
mean when I gave that talk in 2006 for
example the iPhone hadn't even come out
and now people are pretended like life
wasn't possible without being of an
iPhone
well these are baby steps compared to
what's coming down the track you know so
20 years from now we don't know what the
world will look like in terms of job
opportunities so I think pushing people
down this old road on the assumption
that worked for us therefore it'll work
for our kids there's a mistake and
that's what the book is really about
it's just explain to parents the sort of
education that kids need now and the
kind of ways that they can get them amen
no no sorry amen yeah yeah no just if
it's well alright so creativity is
important in decisions our body time
[Laughter]
creativity is important also even if
you're in you know math engineering
physics because the create sometimes
what's new so explain that for people
who think you're just offering sort of
just a pie in the sky stuff this is
important even if you're in science oh
that's right I mean creativity is the
process of having original ideas that
have value it though I think if it is
applied imagination it's putting your
imagination to work and you know we're
in a room that is the result of human
creativity were in front of all these
elaborate technologies we're in
buildings that we're designed we were
enclosed at somebody designer then made
we're sitting at a table it's been
fabricated no the world depends upon
human ingenuity and the problem is in
our school systems and I don't blame
teachers for this at all this testing
mania is crushing the impulse and the
capacity for original thought and we
need that more than ever if you look at
righties were facing around the world so
it's not some fancy thing to be stuck on
the end and it's not just about the arts
the arts are deeply important but so a
science and math and all the rest but we
need more creative approaches to
teaching and learning Thank You mr.
creativity well it's lovely to have you
at the table it's always a pleasure
thank you so much of course was Sir Ken
Robinson to you you your child and
school is available now in paperback